thousands of feet higher up in an
altogether different type of forest
there lives another very special
creature that is also unique to China
the golden snub-nosed monkey only lives
here in the high mountain forests of
central China up to 13,000 feet above
sea level this is the world's largest
high-altitude forest where there are
more tree species than in any other
deciduous forest on earth it's spring
and these monkeys are making the most of
it
[Music]
this troupe has five families each
family has one male and several females
with their young
Nilsa don't belong to these families
hang out together in a monkey bachelor
gang they're an unruly bunch but for now
the focus is not on them it's on the
latest addition to the family a
brand-new baby girl she happens to be
the firstborn this spring
[Music]
so all the females in the family wants a
cuddle this auntie is first then auntie
number two once a hold and auntie number
three
[Music]
enough it's mom time mooning lunchtime
[Music]
in fact all the monkeys want lunch
at this time of year they spend a
quarter of daylight hours eating the
fresh new leaves a good source of
protein and their favorite food
as temperatures rise the monkeys follow
the leaves as they spring to life
further and further up the mountain but
eventually the trees stop growing
[Music]